We are really in an unprecedented situation
in American politics and really in global
politics in a number of different ways.
And we just don't know who we can believe
at this point in time about Donald Trump's
condition when it comes to having contracted
Corona virus and being hospitalized since
last week.
The president of the United States just four
weeks plus one day.
That's where we are today.
Four weeks plus one day from a presidential
election is in the hospital with a case of
Corona virus, the same Corona virus that he
and his administration have downplayed for
months and even ridiculed Joe Biden for taking
seriously and wearing a mask and distancing
and having small crowds at his events.
And in addition to this, the Trump administration
is not coming clean with the seriousness of
Donald Trump's condition.
Now, I am not alleging that Donald Trump is
deathly ill.
But what is abundantly clear from the clips
I'm going to play for you later today is that
Donald Trump's doctors are not and have not
been telling the truth about Donald Trump's
health situation from the start.
But to begin with, let's cut through all of
the B.S. and speculation and talking points
and just focus on what we know.
There are two possibilities here.
Either Donald Trump is being given tons of
treatment despite having almost no symptoms,
merely as a precaution because he's the president,
which puts him at significant risk of side
effects.
And you'll hear why in a moment.
Or his coronavirus is much more serious than
his being admitted or as a third possibility,
which I raised, not because I believe it,
but because I know there will be people who
will write to me and say, you know, David,
the third possibility is he doesn't really
have corona virus and it's all a sham.
I don't believe that that is the case.
I believe the political route is not that
he wouldn't lie about it.
Trump would lie about anything.
It's that it is of unclear benefit to fake
having Corona virus.
I just don't know that it would be a guaranteed
advantage in any way.
So I don't think he would do it.
What we know is that Donald Trump has been
in the hospital since Friday, is overweight.
It's a terrible diet, is in his mid 70s, has
needed supplemental oxygen.
As of this point.
We believe at least two times had a high fever,
at least at one point, and is being given
treatments that most people only get when
they are much more serious.
Why would the White House try to hide the
seriousness of Trump's corona virus, if indeed
that is what they are doing?
Well, for optics and for public relations
purposes.
And in fact, by the time you hear this show
today, it is actually possible that Donald
Trump may have already been discharged from
Walter Reed and be back at the White House.
I'm going to say more about that a little
bit later.
Now, the first red flag that we saw, these
are not my opinions, but these are the opinions
of doctors.
Dr. John Torres explained on NBC that Trump
receiving the steroids dexamethasone is a
major red flag, that Trump is sicker than
the White House is saying.
Why?
Because dexamethasone for Corona virus is
only given when patients have a certain degree
of lung involvement.
That typically would only happen seven to
10 days into the disease.
Donald Trump was given dexamethasone over
the weekend, just a couple of days into treatment.
That is not good.
Number two, once you read through the nonsense
of Donald Trump's doctor, Sean Connelly's
public statements and focus not on the tone,
but on the facts.
Dr. Celine Gounder explains that Trump having
a fever and an oxygen saturation level below
94 on Friday is not mild coronavirus.
As Dr. Gounder explains, when you have oxygen
saturation below 94, that is considered severe
covered period.
Going further, as Dr. Gounder explained on
CNN, Trump was given room, desk, severe room,
desk, severe and dexamethasone are serious
medications given to patients with severe
covered.
And as Dr. Eric Dding explains, dexamethasone
is typically for patients either in the ICU
or on ventilators and sometimes for patients
on oxygen who are going in the wrong direction
in advance of possible ventilation.
The NIH guidelines on dexamethasone, which
are on the screen for our audience, are not
recommended for mild or even moderate cases.
So when we heard yesterday and the day, because
as we heard that Donald Trump might be discharged
today and that may even have happened by the
time that this show gets published, it simply
doesn't line up with the facts that we have.
So if Donald Trump is indeed or has been discharged
today, it would very likely be for optics
purposes, the hyper.
Ethicists would be again.
They've taken the last few days to set up
better medical facilities at the White House
with the goal being to transfer Donald Trump
there and to be able to provide care for a
more serious case at the White House.
But it would be like being at the hospital.
The other possibility, again, because we're
working constantly with incomplete information
from dishonest actors.
Is that all there are?
There is just some bigger picture lie that
is being told here.
And again, this is an administration that
has lied about everything, including Donald
Trump's health for four years.
This is the skepticism that we should be coming
in with.
And case in point, they have been dishonest
at every single opportunity.
Nobody's saying Trump is going to die.
Nobody's saying Trump is in the ICU or on
a ventilator.
But there have been no reasonable explanations
as to how it is that Donald Trump has a mild
case.
It's always been mild.
And every day they say he's improving despite
the fact that he's had fever, has needed oxygen
at least twice, had an oxygen saturation below
94.
And I believe in the 80s, which is a very
serious we'll talk about that later received
an unapproved antibody cocktail and Rham death
severe and dexamethasone.
Is it simply because he's the president starting
to be hard to believe?
This is whatever your belief about Trump is
and mine is that he's horrible.
It is a stressful and scary moment that we
are living through at this time.
We're going to talk next about the lying and
the implications
and
everything else.